alors est-ce que vous avez vous énervez
ou pas je sais ce que vous allez dire
parce que vous avez évoquées et on va
non pas du tout ce que parce que je sais
très bien ce que vous allez faire avec
la banque du coeur et je sais que vous
allez faire et que vous ne mentez pas et
j'en suis persuadé on aurait dit juste
que quand je vois tout cet argent et je
dis juste que quand on peut donner
autant d'argent pour un monument aussi
beau soit-il
ça reste un monument quand je vois tout
cet argent que ces gens sont prêts à
donner
et tout ces gens qui crèvent de faim
quelque part est quelque chose qui me
choque tout ce que je voulais alors je
vais dire mathieu ce qu'il dit là oui on
va tous on va on va arrêter l'hypocrisie
bon là on a vu plein des tweets passé
comme ça on va dire la vérité on en a
tous parlé où l'osm avec maquillage on
s'est tous posé la question on s'est dit
mine de rien là il ya 600 millions
d'euros qu'ils ont donnée donc il faut
arrêter de faire une hypocrisie
bon allez faut pas arrêter de faire
d'hypocrisie on dit les choses il a des
mots clés mathieu je suis assez d'accord
moi voilà je pense chadema nommé mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de gens rient
se pose la question il faut dire la
vérité il faut la mettre sur la table on
est c'est vrai qu'il ya eu énormément de
dons je crois qu'on me dit 600 millions
même un peu plus adroits conte à 800
millions de dons voilà en un jour c'est
énorme et il sait très bien mais c'est
vrai qu'à plein de gens qui se posent la
question sur twitter qui se dit c'est
vrai alors moi je dis on tombe pas sur
ces familles parce que quand on fait
quelque chose on n ait rien sur le
retour des terriens on nous tombe dessus
donc ils ont donné c'est très bien pour
eux mais c'est vrai qu'à plein de gens
qui se posent la question qui se disent
sans jeter la pierre à ces familles qui
ont donné beaucoup d'argent en mine de
rien et moi et moi je lui je le dis
alors il ya des gens qui vont dire c'est
démago le discours de mathieu qui vient
de dire et un instant mais il a raison
de se poser la question quand on voit
qu'il ya énormément de sdf dans la rue
quand on voit qu à plein de gens qui
peuvent pas se loger
mine de rien à un moment on dit rien ces
familles elles ont raison de données il
n'a hélas il va voir 90 % d'abattement
désert casas raison parce que parce que
non mais chut yoplait est à lire voire
90% de l'abattement parce que c'est la
loi puisque 1
c'est un monument historique mais je
vous dis est-ce qu'on peut pas faire une
loi où il ya 90 % d'abattement aussi
quand on donne pour loger des gens qui
sont dans la rue les loger les gens qui
peuvent pas se loger qui ont des
familles entières et que ça franchement
je lis voilà le chef de l'état il a
parlé gastaud franchement pour moi je
pense qu'il faut faire un truc ou même
la 100 % d'abattement
je suis désolé c est réussi
mais après après c'est complètement
autre chose
mais mine de rien je vous le dis sur
twitter il ya plein de gens qui
réagissent et qu'ils aient bas nous
aussi mine de rien duré plus de cinq ans
mais je vous dis en immobilier la 800
millions il ya plus risqués 1 500 barils
non mais c'est vraiment pendant dix ans
comment ça se passe pendant combien de
temps il ya plus de sdf
il faut trouver une solution c'est un
truc quand on donne on leur dit vous
vous débrouillez vous achetez 800
millions construit voilà avec vous
construisez vous souvenez vous le dire
la jambe quand il boit avec couverts
alvin lee ne les blocs plus on ne pleure
plus quand on croise un sdf dans la rue
qui est en train de crever de faim et on
pleure quand on a la cathédrale non mais
on dirait s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît espérions ce cas deux minutes dnp
complot géraldine maillet là excusez moi
je vous aime énormément et la fin des
buts avec l'amour qu'ont à l'impôt mais
non mais jolie mine de rien si vous
pouvez une vers 800 millions de
logements pour des gens aimaient
évidemment et et loger des gens déjà si
l'on peut appuyer leur loyer ou plus est
je peux vous dire et c'est toujours
comme ça dans mes femmes est très bien
où il qu'après ça se passe pas comme ça
oui mais c'est une utopie non mais voilà
pas d'accord et là je comprends qu'ils
aient des gens qui se posent la question
mais voilà c'est très bien l'avoir donné
moi je ne jette pas la pierre à ceux qui
ont donné heureusement les peaux parce
que si l'on va dire quand on doit non de
ferrero n'est fait rien mercredi après
le timing on a l'impression qu'ils ont
en effet deux concours un peu de
quelques riches en un qui donne sens
mais je veux finir parce que c'est nul
ça mais à ces lieux mais à peine ce
qu'on veut mais non j'ai pas ça je vous
dis je dirais mis le times
l'enchaînement des as l'air et les
problèmes qu'a donnée tsonga dont des
doigts sa volée l'enchaînement le timing
à arrêter al hayat en plateau alors pas
donné mais qui donne je le ressens tu
jamais dessus mais je ne tombe pas
dessus mais oui mais la recrue coach me
dit ça on dit n'importe quoi oui moi je
trouve aussi qu'il faut pas tout
mélanger
vous avez vu les gens à moi ce que je
vais régulièrement notre-dame vous avez
vu les gens qui vont à notre dame
c'est pas ni pineau n'y a rien c'est
tout petit bébé justement et c'est cela
qui se propose avant tout de donner non
été assaillis par des gens qui disent
tous les jours
mais surtout c'est pas démago sorte tu
peux craquer tu peux être ému par des
sdf et vouloir aussi donné pourquoi pas
mathieu qui pose la question
c'est au regard des sur huit heures sur
les réseaux sociaux il ya plein de gens
qui se posent la question et qu'ils
disent
et mine de rien c'est vrai quand aux
tons attendre le lever de l'argent on le
lem assez rapidement voilà arrêté ou
d'émissions millions d'euros c'est une
somme exceptionnelle
alors on est jeudi je leur dis bravo à
ceux qui ont donné parce que ça fait
partie du patrimoine français sûr c'est
très important c'est vers mais moi je
vous le dit j'aimerais bien aussi qu'on
puisse voilà lever autant d'argent et
aussi rapidement c'est ça pour des gens
qui sont dans la rue raymond-gernez
partons à vie je partage ton avis parce
que moi d'abord notre dame quand je les
ai vus en feu je dis c'est pas vrai
c'est un cauchemar mauvais film j'y
croyais pas mes yeux moi je crois mes
yeux et là je croyais pas mes yeux dit
merde c'est quoi ce délire
après sur les sommes moi j'étais surpris
en 24 heures si on m'avait dit en six
mois ne seront vingt quatre heures on
m'a sorti si vous pouvez remettre le
tableau quand je vois le tableau 200
millions 100 millions je me dis c'est
pas vrai c'est positif après les mecs
après celle c'est leur argent ils l'ont
gagné ils en font ce qu'ils veulent
chacun la sensibilité de données pour
notre dame et on va pas leur dire on va
pas leur jeter la pierre tant mieux
c'est très bien ce qu'ils font mais moi
je suis un peu comme vous je me dis ça
veut dire que demain alors peut-être pas
peut-être pas donner des logements à
tout le monde parce que comment tu
expliques au mec qui va bosser tous les
matins que les autres sur leur graal à
surya ça aussi c'est compliqué mais
trouver noirs mûrs je supporte pas le
matin à 6h30 on dit aux sdf à les bouger
vous a bien su repartir parce que les
touristes arrivent il faut icai il fait
froid ça crève de faim alors les trêve
hivernale là on m'a sorti des sommes et
on dit qu'il ya encore des gens qui
meurent de faim c'est compliqué quand
même c'est parce que je suis d'accord
avec toi les conversions dans afin de
s'y fait froid alors je dis pas qu'il
faut acheter des appartements à tous les
sdf parce que c'est c'est utopique c'est
vrai je dis moi je rajoute d'acheter des
algécos dans 77 et fou tout le monde
dans un algeco avec du chauffage et
leurs amis à manger tous les jours
les restos du coeur ont dit 1 euro 1 re
paris mais regardez ce que le ch les cif
qu'on me sorte quand j'entends les
restos du coeur les restos me dise
lâcheté un euro c'est un repas cyril 100
millions en 24 heures
ce que n'avait rien dit quand vous dit
on reprocherait à donateurs mais mine de
rien ça prouve qu'en france et dans le
monde quand on connait tous d'argent
très rapidement et et 20 mois moi ce qui
me touche et jeudi les voilà qui est on
va voir des gens dans la rue
des gens des familles entières qui
peuvent pas finir à pour qui là les fins
de mois c'est le disent c'est le 10 du
mois on a vu tout le mouvement des gilet
jaune
ces derniers temps mine de rien les
gilet jaune je le dis à chaque fois pour
la plupart c'est la plupart des français
parce que il ya plein de français qui
sont en difficulté eh ben mine de rien
et j'aimerais bien aussi que ça bouge
aussi vite pour eux je vous dis la
vérité après comme vous dites on peut
pas acheter un appartement tout ce que
le mec dans lequel tous les matins et
ben moi je me lève pulpe est pas aussi
aggravé cyril mai mais je vous dis que
j'aimerais qu'on trouve un moyen voilà
d'aidé avec l'argent qu'il est très
agréable de ce qu'on vient voir là et
pardon je sais ce qui est très grave
c'est que le tableau qu'on vient de voir
là ça c'était en 24 heures donc c'est de
l'argent de l'émotion ça veut dire que
ces gens qui ont donné autant d'argent
24 heures c'est dû à l'émotion et ça
veut dire que ces gens étaient plus
émues de toi je vais vous dire des fans
de foot et des goûters dans la la je
vais vous dire ce qu'ils ont fait et
bravo à eux à ces familles là moi je dis
bravo parce que qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait ils sont dix mille noria ont fait
partie des familles les plus riches de
france et on doit on doit conserver et
on doit ré et on doit pouvoir se battre
pour que la france garde son patrimoine
et ils sont dit on va se mobiliser et
bravo à eux et on va donner beaucoup
d'argent
moi c'est pas sûr que je tombe c'est
juste que on est capable de mobiliser
beaucoup d'argent et que de faire les
deux et que mine de rien en très peu de
temps et je pose qui est au contraire
moche et ça ça ça me donne de l'espoir
mais je vous le dis et je me dis mine de
rien ya peut-être un truc a fait un
mobile vont mobiliser beaucoup de gens
exigeants là bravo à eux ils se sont
mobilisés très vite et je suis persuadé
qu'ils peuvent se mobiliser pour
d'autres choses
voilà c'était sans doute passer des
soirées toutes séries mais rose à ces
parties rivales ou libourne et gille et
joli métier
pardon jimmy écoutez c'est vrai que
quand on voit l'image oui c'est triste
mais je suis désolé moi si je perds ça
n'a pas plus touchés que ça mais quand
je repense à l' incendie par exemple de
la rue myrha à marseille qui a fait des
morts bah oui a eu autant d'indignation
alors oui c'est notre dame où c'est la
france mais le quotidien c'est peut-être
autre chose et quand je vois qu'on
débloque autant d'argent pour ça et que
à marseille
de l'autre côté on a des familles qui
ont galéré plusieurs jours plusieurs
semaines à être hébergés dans des
centres sociaux quand je vois le présent
dire nous allons vite rebâtir nous
sommes un pays de conquérant mais
allez-y il ya des choses à faire
donc l'indignation moi je la trouve je
vais vous dire grâce à ces gens là
grâce à ces gens là aussi oui les très
riches chouly l'ont ils ont sauvé il ya
plein de gens qui lui aussi
ils ont aussi sauvé nos impôts parce que
sinon on l'aurait retrouvé sur la
feuille d'impôts
et il ya plein de français ce site où le
rafale est donc mercialys a bien sûr
pineau bettencourt et arnaud qui paye
plutôt que la région île de france par
exemple et la mairie de paris
j'aime que les fonds privés comme
absolument nous comme à rome par exemple
ont rénové thompson arrive à le briser
humains s'empare de nos biens et de
notre histoire tous pour rénover le
patrimoine plutôt que ce soit de nos
impôts dgi on restera là tant qu'on ses
téléspectateurs parce que et je suis
d'accord avec ce que vous avez dit jimmy
mais moi je vous le dis et je le redis
pour moi franchement c'est de l'espoir
je mets bien mignon vous avez vu comme
on peut rien vous savez pas garde on
sait peu de temps mais encore plus les
gens nous ont dit qu'on a bien sûr qui
déjà en oeuvre pour 2 pers exactement de
l'argent et peut-être qu'ils en donnent
ailleurs des mesures non mais ils en
donnent tous ailleurs ils ont inhalé
vais me reposer mais bravo moi je dis
franchement bravo à eux c'est un motif
d'espoir et je vous dis il ya quand même
des gens voilà qu'ils disent c'est
normal sur twitter qui se posent la
cabine série mais on ne peut pas leur
tomber dessus le font de façon moins
visible
toute l'année ils donnent pour des mêmes
chez eux il ya des nations fiscale mais
donne toute l'année pour des
associations caritatives
il ya quelques années ben eager s'est
donné cinq milliards pour l'afrique pour
réduire le résoudre le problème du
paludisme
il ya aussi les grandes fortunes donne
aussi pour dominer le talent de la
communauté faire un bras d'honneur à
tout à tous à tous les gilet jaune
puisque je rappelle que les scellés
gilet jaune recettes de l'augmentation
de l'essence total ne paie pas on le
sait ne paient pas d'impôts le cac 40
s'est 7% en moyenne des impôts et les
non pas donner 1 euro pour les gilet
jaune avec monaco il verse en 1905
millions et millions au total
et aujourd'hui avait un bras d'honneur
au gilet jaune